[Music]
our father and our
God it's been a wonderful
day every Sabbath is a wonderful
day and father we ask that as we open
your
word and reflect upon the issues that
are facing your church that your Holy
Spirit will be present through the
ministry of the angels to guide our
thought we love this
church we love the Seventh Day Adventist
Church we know it will go through till
the end but it faces many struggles
today help us Lord to understand what
the issues are and give us the kindness
and the love and at the same time the
determination to
share what God God shows us what you
show us concerning the great things that
are occurring and we thank you Father
for the privilege of prayer and for
hearing us because we ask it in the
precious name of Jesus
Amen there are two dangerous
extremes when we talk about
God the first extreme is what is known
as
deism
this idea is that God is totally
Transcendent and is radically
disconnected from his
creation God created the world according
to this View and then he bid the world
farewell allowing it to function on the
basis of fixed laws that he
established an
absentee creator
the other dangerous
extreme the one that we are facing today
especially in the 7th Day Adventist
Church is known as
pantheism or
panentheism where God is imminent within
creation and is
indistinguishable from
creation the Bible does not agree with
either of these
Extremes in the Bible God is a
person Ellen White
asked Jesus whether his father had a
form such as
himself and Jesus said yes he has a
form but if you you should
see for an instant the glory of his
person you would cease to ex
exist Ellen White also explains that we
were created physically mentally and
spiritually in the image of God which
means that God is a
person he is a real person that inhabits
in a real
place called
Heaven God is outside of his
creation therefore he is distinct and
separate from it he is the cause and
creation is the
effect but the Bible also tells us that
God enters into contact with his
creation he sustains it he cares for
it he counts the numbers of hairs on our
heads and each day he has to adjust the
number on my head I might
say he provides for The Sparrows
and he cares enough about us that he was
willing to send his only begotten son to
save us and the
world in other words there is a balance
between the Transcendence and the
imminence of God God is a person Beyond
Creation in a place called heaven but he
enters into contact with his creation
if I had to use one Bible verse that
presents these
two aspects of God it would be Isaiah 57
and verse
15 and I read that
verse for thus
says the high and lofty
one who inhabits
eternity whose name is
Holy
I dwell here is God speaking I dwell in
the high and holy
Place God as a person is in
heaven that's why we pray Our Father
which art in
heaven so he says I dwell in the high
and holy place but then the verse
continues saying also with him who has a
contrite and humble Spirit to revive the
spirit of the humble and to revive the
heart of the contrite
ones he dwells in the high and lofty
place called heaven but he also comes
into contact with those of us who are
here on
Earth who according to this are contrite
and humble in
spirit Satan has a counterfeit
for everything that God has
true and so for a few minutes I would
like to talk about the devil's
counterfeit I call it new age
meditation for those who
Embrace New Age
philosophy God is not a
person who lives in a place called
heaven but God is rather an impersonal
Essence that permeates the entire
universe according to New Age thinking
and what I'm going to share now is very
important according to New Age
thinking
Consciousness and by the way
Consciousness is defined as the fact
that you are aware of
yourself and your
surroundings and that you are aware that
you are
aware that's what consciousness means so
according to New Age thinking
Consciousness and
personality get in the way of
Oneness with the impersonal Universal
Consciousness in order to shut out
Consciousness and return to the
impersonal Universal essence you must
escape space and
time
therefore you cannot think about
anything concrete in historical
experience because this causes
stress and brings back negative
memories because all of the events of
our lives are tied to time and space so
the idea is to escape time and
space so you es Escape personality
you see memories are based on events
that took place in space and time and
therefore the Mind must transcend space
and time according to New Age
thinking you must empty your
mind of all memories of events past
present and even
future this will help your mind go into
to
neutral and experience absolute
rest and
silence then you can hear the voice of
God within you without any
distractions that's the way that new age
thinking
goes the way that this is accomplished
among Eastern
Mystics is to practice the art of
Transcendental
Meditation where you escape time and
space
and are at one with the impersonal
universe or the impersonal
God for the Believers in New Age
philosophy reaching
Nirvana is the
ideal where personality and
Consciousness have been
extinguished and you have returned to
nothingness you have ceased to exist as
a conscious time and space person
in New Age philosophy of course the goal
is the goal of meditation is to make
your brain totally passive and to empty
it of all of its
content during the
1960s Transcendental Meditation became
very
common and some of those who practice
Transcendental Meditation use drugs to
enter Altered States of consciousness
drugs such as
LSD the purpose was to transcend reality
as we know
it probably the most famous individual
who brought Transcendental Meditation to
the West Was A guy by the NAA Maharishi
mahes
Yogi who influenced greatly The
Beatles who took drugs to enter these
altered stat of
Consciousness now you're probably
wondering why is Pastor B
mentioning
pantheism why is he mentioning an escape
from time and space why is he talking
about New Age philosophy that says that
the goal is to empty your mind totally
and completely of thinking of
Consciousness the reason is that for
everything that God has
true the devil has a Christian
confit
let me read you some
statements by individuals who claim to
be
Christians willigis
Jagger a Roman Catholic Benedictine
monk stated
this speaking about contemplative
prayer do not
reflect on the meaning of the word he's
talking about using a mantra a
repetitive word
thinking and reflecting must
cease as all mystical writers
insist simply sound the word
silently letting go of all feelings and
thoughts this is a Christian writing
sounds very similar to New Age
philosophy William Johnson
a Jesuit priest and a Zen
Buddhist definitely an
oximoron if you ask
me wrote this when one enters the deeper
layers of contemplative
prayer one sooner or later experiences
the
void the word void means empty by the
way experience is the void the empty
the
nothingness the profound mystical
silence an absence of
thought interesting isn't
it Brennon Manning a former Roman
Catholic Mystic suggested this stop
thinking repeat the word that is the
Mantra slowly and and
often and enter the great Silence of
God and the voice of love will be
heard I want you to remember that
because a little bit later on we're
going to come back to
that once again enter the great Silence
of God and the voice of love will be
heard Richard Foster one of the most
famous of these Mystics
who is a
Quaker wrote
this in your
imagination and this is scary
stuff in your
imagination allow your spiritual body
shining with light to rise out of your
physical
body reassure your body that you will
return go deeper and deeper into outer
space
until there is
nothing except the warm presence of the
Eternal
Creator rest in his presence listen
quiet quietly to any instruction
given I was interested in uh Janet's uh
mentioning The Cloud of un
knowing see the goal of these Christian
Mystics is to I
know to empty the mind to have a void in
your brain thinking is the enemy because
it's attached to time and
space and events of time and space
distract us from experiencing The
Silence by the
way all of these individuals that I've
mentioned are being recommended as
reading in seventh day
colleges including our
Seminary at Andrews
University all of these individuals are
Mystics you say what is the word what
does mysticism mean the word mysticism
comes from the word the Greek word
Mo and it means to
conceal so the mystics are claiming to
acquire information directly from God
that is inaccessible or concealed to the
intellect let me read you a couple of
Def definitions that are given of
mysticism in different
dictionaries mysticism is the belief
that Union with or absorption into the
deity or the
absolute or the spiritual apprehension
of knowledge inaccess accessible to the
intellect may be attained through
contemplation and self-
surrender so once again it's the idea
that you're coming into Union with
you're being absorbed into the deity or
the
absolute and you're acquiring
information that is inaccessible to your
intellect in other words put your brain
in neutral don't think is the
idea and this comes comes according to
this definition through contemplation
and selfs
surrender another definition that is
given for mysticism in another
dictionary is the belief that direct
knowledge of
God spiritual
truth or Ultimate
Reality can be attained through
subjective
experience that is totally contrary to
sth day
adventism in our church we believe that
objective truth is found in a
book outside of
man in
scripture not in the subjective
experience of the individual and yet
this definition says that Mystics have
the belief that direct knowledge of God
spiritual truth or Ultimate
Reality may be attained through cont may
be obtained through a subjective
experience thus Mystics do not believe
that they receive ultimate truth from an
objective Source such as the Bible they
believe they get it directly and
subjectively by listening to the voice
of God through contemplation and
prayer Ellen
White by the way uses the word
mysticism and I'd like to read one
statement where she uses the word
mysticism and I want you to notice all
the relatives that are found in this
statement evangelism page
606 there are many who shrink with
horror from the thought of Consulting
Spirit
mediums would you shrink in hor about
Consulting a spirit
medium most adven would but now notice
what she continues
saying she says there are many who
shrink with horror from the thought of
Consulting Spirit mediums but who are
attracted by more pleasing forms of
spiritism such as the Emmanuel movement
I won't go into that right
now still others are let astray by the
teachings of Christian
Science Mary Baker Eddie pure
spiritualism and by m the mysticism of
theosophy and other
Oriental
religions notice what she links together
spiritualism
spiritism mysticism of theosophy and the
Oriental religions which would include
Buddhism and Hinduism as the two best
known now somebody might
argue don't you have to empty your mind
of all the darkness before you can fill
it with God's glorious light
doesn't that sound
logical it sounds logical but let's take
a closer look at this so-called
logic if you're in a dark
room do you need to empty the room of
darkness before you can fill it with a
light of course
not you fill the room with light and the
Darkness will take care of
itself
so this idea that we need to empty our
minds so we can hear God's voice and
then we can fill
it is a very dangerous
idea Ellen White also referred to Dr
Kellogg's
mysticism and I like to read this
statement because it has very important
elements in it it's found in selected
messages Volume 2 page
202 listen carefully to what she says
she's speaking about the book The Living
Temple we need not the mysticism that is
in this
book see calls the book by Kellog what
mysticism now notice this those who
entertain these
sophistries will soon find themselves in
a
position where the enemy can talk with
them is there any danger that if you to
your
mind that there might be another voice
other than the voice of God speaking to
you notice how she connects mysticism
with the idea that the enemy can speak
with you once again we need not the
mysticism that is in this book those who
entertain these sophistries will soon
find themselves in a position where the
enemy can talk with them and lead them
away from
God it is represented to me that the
writer of this book
is on a false track and now notice why
he is on a false track he has lost sight
of the distinguishing truths for this
time you'll find that those who are
dabbling in all this contemplative
prayer and all this mysticism in the sth
Day Adventist Church they totally
downgrade the distinctiveness of the
Adventist
Church they're ecumenical in their
Outlook they they don't want much said
about Bible prophecy they don't want
much use of Ellen White because Ellen
White would condemn many of the things
that are taking
place in other words many of the things
that distinguish the Adventist Church
from other churches are simply swept
under the
rug and so Ellen White States regarding
Kell he has lost sight of the
distinguishing truths for this time he
knows not wither his steps are
trending the now notice this the track
of truth lies close beside the track of
error and both tracks may seem to be one
to Minds which are not worked by the
Holy Spirit and which therefore are not
quick to discern the difference between
truth and
error you know these ideas are presented
as very beautiful you know brings God so
much closer to you that's one of the
things that Kellogg argued it brings God
so close to you you know he's not up
there sitting on his throne you know you
can enter the universal consciousness of
God you can hear God speaking to you
directly apart from a book it sounds
beautiful but error is very close to
truth the devil makes it that way you
know the devil doesn't tell lies such as
this you see this coat it's
red who did that
deceive well maybe those who are
colorblind but this coat is not red it's
blue navy
blue now what would the devil do he
might say this coat is
black
ah that would be a little bit closer
wouldn't it because you really can't
tell whether it's black or whether it's
navy blue
that's the way that the devil
works now contemporary Christian
writers use different terminology the
new AG
thinkers and some people are deceived
because of the
terminology they call their practice
contemplative prayer centering
prayer Listening
Prayer according to them the goal of
prayer is to experience the silence
and when you experience the
silence all thinking is
suspended and you come into direct
contact with God who speaks directly to
you now what happens if you're uh
practicing contemplative prayer and your
mind kind of gets distracted you know
it's difficult to meditate and to focus
your mind gets distracted with the many
things that you have to take care of
during the course of the day so what
happens well some writers are even
saying that you should use the idea of a
mantra using a word and repeating it
over and over again when your mind
becomes distracted you repeat that word
and it causes kind of like self
hypnosis and then you're able to
concentrate
again incidentally the word
Mantra means it comes from two words in
Sanskrit man which means to think and ra
which means to be liberated
from so Mantra means to be liberated
from
thinking
interesting now who are the main thought
leaders of this idea of contemplative
prayer and spiritual
formation the fact is folks that these
ideas come from Roman
Catholicism ultimately
uh you know you go back to St Ignatius
lyola who uh established the Society of
Jesus in
1534 he wrote what are known as the
spiritual exercises which is basically
spiritualism it's contemplative prayer
all the way back to that
time and these ideas came into
protestantism through Roman
Catholicism and they have penetrated
into to the sth Day Adventist Church
from both Catholicism and from apostate
protestantism the thought leaders I'll
mention some of
them Richard
Foster who wrote a book that is a
bestseller sold Millions the celebration
of
discipline Thomas keing a Roman Catholic
ecumenist williges Jagger a Roman cathol
Catholic Benedictine Monk and master of
Zen
Buddhism a Catholic priest Henry Nan who
taught at Notre Dame Harvard and
Yale others are William Johnston who is
a Jesuit priest and also Zen Buddhist
Thomas meron Leonard
s probably of all of these individuals
that I mentioned the most recognized in
the Adventist Church are Leonard sweet
and Richard
Foster those two books are recommended
reading in some of our theology schools
in the sth Day Adventist
Church Protestants to a greater or
lesser degree have assimilated these
views individuals like Max
luo Philip
yansy Amy
Grant Even Rick Warren has read
recommended several books on his
website written by these Christian
Mystics now folks Satan tried to
introduce a crude kind of pantheism into
the sth Adventist
Church at the beginning of the 20th
century he attempted to
import Hinduism basically into the 7th
aist church because that's what
Kellogg's ideas were according to Elder
Spicer who had an interview with
him by the help of Ellen
White these attacks were
defeated but now Satan is working under
the
radar he makes those theories appear
much more beautiful and
meaningful but it's the same
heresy garbed in nicer
clothing Ellen White had a very
interesting statement you know she
didn't know what to call Kellogg's
ideas she struggled with finding an an
expression that would describe
it I'd like to read from Volume 8 of the
10 testimonies page 292 God revealed to
her the exact words that she needed to
call these theories
by I read
now I have seen the results of these
fful views of
God in
apostasy
spiritualism and free
loveism
H she continues saying the free love
tendency of these
teachings notice she calls it free
loveism and then she says the free love
tendency of these teachings was so
concealed that at first it was difficult
to make plain its real
character even the
prophet didn't know what to call
it and according to her it was difficult
to make plain its real
character until the Lord presented it to
me I knew not what to call it but I was
instructed to call it Unholy spiritual
love
now let's unpack that just for a few
moments according to the Bible what is
love God is love where is the character
of God
reflected in his holy
law what the devil has done is he has
led the Christian world to believe that
love and law can be
separated then you can be a law to
yourself
the Bible tells us that love is the
fulfilling of the
LA he who says he knows him does not
keep his Commandments is a
liar the Bible defines love as keeping
God's objective law which is outside of
man but these pantheistic
ideas tell you that you don't really
need an objective source of Truth
you don't need a law outside of you
telling you what's right and
wrong you've got that
Insight you know who the PO first
postmodern in the history of the
universe was
Lucifer elen white states that Lucifer
in
heaven
said to God you know we we want to be
delivered from the
law you know the worlds might need a law
because they're inferior to us but us
angels we don't need a law outside of
us because our own will will always lead
us to the
right in other words their source of
Ethics was not
outside it was
inside and then of course he came down
on to this
earth and he says you will be like
God and notice he said you be like God
in a certain
way you will be like God knowing good
and evil let me ask you who was it that
defined good and evil was that inside of
them no God said eating from this tree
is
evil eating from all of the other trees
is good I find for you from outside of
you what is good and what is
evil but the devil is telling Eve you
don't have to depend on God to tell you
what is good and evil if you eat from
the tree you will know from inside how
to distinguish good from
Evil and that is one of the fundamental
problems of this view that is
penetrating the Seventh Day Adventist
Church it's the view that all you need
is love all you need is
Jesus and I agree that all you need is
love and all you need is is Jesus as
long as you define love in the proper
way and as long as you understand what
it means to love Jesus Jesus said if you
love me do as you
please
no Jesus said if you love
me keep my
Commandments love is the fulfilling of
the
law the primary objective of the devil
in all of this is to get people to
follow their own source of
Ethics to be a law unto themselves a
free love tendency free of
what free of the
law that is the ultimate
goal Ellen White
explained that what occurred in her days
was the
alpha of deadly
heresies and she said that the
Omega would follow and I believe I
firmly believe as I've examined many of
the
writings and I've listened to many
lectures on this emerging Church idea
this contemplative prayer spiritual
formation you know I don't know how you
cannot see
that this is the Omega attempting to
penetrate God's Remnant church at this
time it's just absolutely
clear Ellen White stated this is found
in selective messages volume 1 page 200
in the book The Living Temple there is
presented the alpha of deadly
heresies the Omega will follow and will
be received by those who are not willing
to heed the warning that God has
given you know you might not have
understood everything that you've heard
here this
weekend so I would like to encourage you
to read seven
books the perfect
number and I'm going to mention those
books they will be available after
Sundown by the
way because I believe it's important
these books books are very easy to
understand and I'm trying to go go in
chronological
order there's a book that was written a
while ago by an individual who was and
you're probably saying what is the fine
art of Christian meditation we're going
to come to that we have to talk about
the counterfeit before we talk about the
genuine
right we're going to draw
contrast our Union president at that
time was Thomas
moard and as it was about to retire he
wrote a very captivating book called
called hidden
heresy every Adventist should read that
book it doesn't deal directly with
spiritual
formation but it shows the contrast
between what the Evangelical World
emphasizes and what the Seventh
Adventist Church emphasizes he shows how
the Evangelical World hides God's holy
law and the distinctives of the
Adventist
Church then there's a book that's very
close to my heart it was written by
Steven bour
it's called worship at Satan's
Throne I think every admin should read
that book not because I wrote
it is a very important
book basically I analyze in that book
the message to the Philadelphian Church
where where we're told that the
synagogue of Satan is in the Church of
Philadelphia and that's that's the
Church of the millerite
movement
and then I also have a chapter where I
deal with Ellen White's Throne
Vision where the father and the son are
sitting on the throne the father gets up
goes into the most holy place then the
son gets up and goes into the most holy
place there's a multitude of people
kneeling next to the throne in the Holy
Place those who kept their eyes on Jesus
move into the most holy place with him
by faith most of the world remains
kneeling kneeling before the throne and
and Ellen White says that those who were
oblivious to Jesus moving into the most
holy place where we find all of the
distinctive truths of the Adventist
Church remain kneeling before the throne
and Ill white explains that Satan took
the place that Jesus
vacated and the people there at the foot
of the throne prayed father give us your
spirit and the devil would Breathe upon
them an evil
influence and in that evil influence
there were Miracles and signs and
wonders and power and counterfeit
light which they thought was the power
of
God but it was the power of the enemy
because they did not go into the most
holy place but the most scary part of
this Vision the portion that's not in
early writings which Ellen White added
later is that she states that many of
those who entered by faith with Jesus
into the most holy place then
backtracked and knelt in the Holy place
and they received the influ evil
influence of Satan
and so it's a very important book then
we have that classic book The Omega
Rebellion Rick Howard and also he wrote
the book me it which is a follow-up to
that book very easy to read very
simple then we have a book by Howard pth
the dangers of contemplative prayer it's
a good summary very easy to understand
then we have Dave feedler
the book
tremble Ellen White said that she
trembled for our people when she saw
this heresy come in into the church and
then finally one book that I would like
to especially
mention is from a seminary teacher that
I had 40 years ago now I've aged myself
to you carsten
Johnson phenomenal philosopher one of
the great philosophers in the history of
the aist church you probably never heard
of his
name he was very humble unassuming I
believe had three doctorates super
intelligent super
educated he anticipated what is
happening in the Adventist Church four
decades
ago this is almost a prophetic book I
said almost I'm not saying that he was a
prophet we felt at Secrets unsealed that
this is such an important book that we
edited it and we decided to republish it
because he basically published his own
books there at the Seminary you know and
and I mean the style just wasn't there
the content was there there were lots of
um mistakes you know in terms of
spelling and syntax and grammar and so
we had to correct all of those things
it's a philosophical work and
particularly the last part of the book
it's like you're reading what is
happening in the Adventist Church today
and it was written 40 years ago
carsten
jonssen uh the Mystic Omega of End Time
Crisis the Mystic Omega of End Time
Crisis now basically
folks what Satan is attempting to do is
he is attempting to convince Christians
to not follow the Bible as the objective
source of ethics and
Truth at its very
foundation in the book this day with
God page
21 Ellen White States this now listen
carefully Satan is making the world
believe that the Bible is a mere
fiction or at least a book suited to the
infancy of the
race but now to be lightly regarded or
cast aside as
obsolete in now notice what she
says and to take place to take the place
of the word of
God he holds out spiritual
manifestations so he says cast the Bible
aside as objective truth and then he
says in its place spiritual
manifestations and why she says this
here is a channel wholly under his
control
by this means he can make the world
believe what he
will the book that is to judge him and
his
followers he puts in the
shade just where he wants it the savior
of the world he makes to be no more than
a common
man you look at all the philosophies
that have proliferated in the last 50 or
60 years let me just mention some of
them they're all
based on an internal
ethical standard for your
decisions you have
existentialism the ordinary version of
that is the hippies they were
existentialists existentialism
spiritualism pantheism contemplative
prayer the emerging Church postmodern
thinking valous clarification Neo
Orthodoxy situation ethics New Age
philosophy
psychoanalysis and psychology it's all
based
on the internal
standard rather than the word of
God now let's talk about genuine
Christian
meditation talked about the
counterfeit now let's talk about the
genuine in Christian meditation folks
the mind is actively
involved this method of meditation is
based on
reflection
musing
remembering
thinking
reasoning it does not mean putting your
mind in
neutral it means filling your mind with
the word of
God it's a dangerous thing to empty your
mind and then not fill it
up let me just read from Luke 11:2
24-26 when an unclean Spirit goes out of
a
man he goes through the dry places
seeking
rest and finding
none he says I will return to my house
from which I
came and when he comes he finds it swept
and put in
order then he goes and takes with him
seven other Spirits more wicked than
himself and they enter and dwell there
and the last state of that man is worse
than the
first
never get the idea that it's God's plan
for us to empty our mind to put our mind
in
neutral to experience the
void genuine meditation and prayer does
not consist in vain repetition emptying
the
mind but it means filling your mind with
the promises of
God now what is the main OB obstacle to
medit
ation it's the hustle and bustle of Life
folks see the reason people today are
looking for a spiritual
experience let's let's just
admit that to a great degree we have
failed in supplying that genuine
spiritual experience because of the
hustle and bustle of life because of the
rat race of
materialism people are hungering and
thirsting for for an
experience but that experience must be
based upon the word of God it cannot be
based upon only your own subjective
experience we need time to be
silent we need time for
meditation and time for
reflection but not with the mind in
neutral but with the mind in full
activity in the Adventist home page 521
Ellen White
describes why people today have very
little discipline when it comes to
meditating you know you really look all
you have to do is look at
television how can the church compete
with
television you know people people blame
the church for the loss of our young
people from church they say you know the
church is to
blame there's a lot of blame to go
around parents
School
culture the student
themselves they have freedom of
choice but you
see these days you you watch a
television program and the scenes are
changing every
instant the mind is totally you know the
mind doesn't even know what to focus
on that's the reason why you know
when you're saying okay let's just sit
down and let's reflect upon this passage
of scripture
boring that's what you
hear because Bible study cannot be as
exciting as all these change of scenes
on television video games and all and
and all these
things and so the mind has to be
re-educated and that's the difficult
part I had to re-educate my mind I won't
tell you my
experience because there's not time but
I had to re-educate my mind you know do
you have to re-educate your taste if
you're if you're used to eating all
kinds of junk food do you say okay I'll
be a vegan beginning
today you know it's not that easy it
takes time and effort but it's worth the
investment so the church needs to offer
young people what the world doesn't
offer them if we offer them the same
thing the world does why should they
come to
church this is what Ellen White says in
this age of the world there is an
unprecedented rage for
pleasure dissipation what would you say
today dissipation and Reckless
extravagance Prevail
everywhere the multitudes are eager for
amusement the Mind becomes trifling and
frivolous because it is is not
accustomed to meditation or disciplined
study why does the Mind become trifling
and and frivolous because it is not
accustomed to meditation or disciplined
to
study she goes on to say ignorant
sentimentalism is
current sentimentalism means to you know
guide your life by your emotions and
your feelings
God requires that every soul shall be
cultivated refined elevated and
ennobled but too often every valuable
attainment is neglected for fashionable
display and
superficial
pleasure now let me give you some
tips that I found
useful with regards to Christian
meditation because it it's not enough to
say they're doing it wrong we need to
also share how to do it right
the best time for Christian meditation
is early in the
morning before the hustle and bustle of
the
day you know at that time you get
up perhaps before everybody else
does it's
quiet you can go
outside breathe some fresh
air that's the best time your mind is
fresh because you just got up
so early in the morning is the best
time Point number two choose a quiet
comfortable peaceful place where there
are no
distractions Jesus it says that he went
out to a mountain very early in the
morning to commune with his
father if you're in the house some soft
background music might be good I'm not
talking about Christian rock now that
will distract you and I'm not talking
about New Age Style
music which will make your mind go
dormant choose a passage from
scripture to meditate
upon and focus upon that
passage pray that the holy spirit will
help your mind to
dwell on what you're
reading read the passage several times
thinking about it and reading
it if possible memorize
it I have a gentleman who's 96 year old
years old in my church Randall
loots still memorize this scripture
couple of weeks ago he recited Isaiah 35
from the pul from the pulpit didn't miss
a
beat
96 years
old we've lost the art of
memorization we become lazy
mentally you know we don't even know how
to add and subtract and multiply
anymore because a calculator doeses it
all no mental effort we're becoming
mental
pygmies 7th ADV Bible commentary volume
6 page 1085 Ellen White says you need to
dwell upon the assurances of God's word
to hold them before the Mind's
Eye Point by
Point day by day repeat the lessons
they're given over and over doesn't say
recite a
mantra it says recite over and over the
lesson that you're learning from the
passage she says we see a little
today and by meditation and prayer more
tomorrow
and thus little by little we take in the
gracious promises until we can almost
com comprehend their full
significant it's okay for you to close
your eyes and recreate the scene in your
mind use your
imagination don't speculate or go beyond
scripture but use your mind to grow Gras
the passage that you're looking
at if your mind wanders don't repeat a
mantra and don't get
frustrated simply come back and refocus
and pray to the Lord that the Lord will
help you keep your
focus and finally put into practice what
you meditated
about in the Bible
meditation always as intentional
it always involves objective
truth I want to read you a few texts
from scripture and then just two or
three from the spirit of Prophecy as we
close some 119 3 997 to
99 here David says oh how I love your
law it is my meditation all the day
what was David's meditation
like he was emptying his mind no he was
filling it with God's
law and then he says you through your
Commandments make me wiser than my
enemies for they are ever with for your
testimonies are my
meditation his law and his test
testimonies are to be our
meditation Joshua 1
ver8 this book of the law shall not
depart from your mouth but you shall
meditate in it day and
night see once again the law of
God the book of the law meditate on it
day and night and then comes the result
that you may observe to do according to
all that is written in it for then you
will make your way prosperous and then
you will have good
success Psalm 1 was referred to Psalm
111 and2 blessed is the man who walks
not in the counsel of the ungodly nor
stands in the path of Sinners nor sits
in the seat of the
scornful but his Delight is in the law
of the Lord there it is again his
Delight is in the law of the Lord and in
his law he meditates day and night once
again in his law he meditates Day and
Night by the word the by the way the
word law here is
Torah it means all of God's revelation
all of God's objective
Revelation Psalm
63:6 speaking about what happened while
a person was laying on his bed when I
remember you on my
bed that tells you where I meditate on
you that tells you
what in the night watches that tells you
when because that tells you why you have
been my help therefore in the shadow of
your wings I Will Rejoice that's the
result so we have everything in that one
verse there are many many
other scriptures that I could read the
word meditate is so common in the Psalms
cont contemplate is common in the
Psalms and those who are meditating are
not meditating
just a nothing they're not attempting to
empty their minds they're attempting to
fill their minds so that their behavior
will be impact it and
affected let me just read you two or
three quotations from the spirit of
Prophecy there's so many of them
here it would would be well for us to
spend a thoughtful hour each
day in contemplation of the Life of
Christ does that involve
thinking does it involve
uh
hearing what is happening in the
story does it involve seeing what is
happening in the story it most certainly
does when we read it don't just read it
meditate on it think of it
as if you were
there it would be well for us to spend a
thoughtful hour each day in
contemplation of the Life of Christ we
should take it Point by
point and let the
imagination grasp each
scene especially the closing
ones and now notice the consequences of
that as we thus
dwell what does it mean to
dwell oh this is a permanent thing as we
thus dwell upon his great sacrifice for
us our confidence in him will be more
constant our love will be
quickened and we shall be more deeply
imbued with his
Spirit if we would be saved at last we
must learn the lesson of penitence
and
humiliation at the foot of the
cross you know we overcome sin not by
beholding the law but by beholding
Jesus of course Jesus is the
personification of the law it's not
either or it's
both I've never been able to understand
how Christians can say the law was
nailed to the C cross but we love
Jesus
if the law is a reflection of the
character of Jesus so to crucify the law
is to crucify Jesus because the law is a
reflection of who he
is are you following
me just let me read two
more notice the number of times that
Ellen White uses here the word
behold this is Bible Echo November 1
1893 Behold the Lamb of God which taketh
away the sin of the
world I repeat the words of John Behold
the Lamb of God we are to contemplate
the character of
Christ we are to meditate upon the cross
of Calvary for it is the unanswerable
argument of
Christianity the message we are to Bear
to the impenitent the warning we are to
give to the backslider is Behold the
Lamb of God which taketh away the sin of
the world those who bring the message to
the soul may turn aside from the
truth but he who would be saved must
keep his eye on
Jesus by beholding Christ he will learn
to hate
sin that has brought to his Redeemer
suffering and death by
beholding his faith become strong
and he comes to know the only true God
and Jesus Christ whom he has sent the
sinner sees Jesus as he is full of
compassion and tender love and by
beholding there's the word again by
beholding the manifestation of his great
love towards Fallen man in his
sufferings on Calvary he is transformed
in
character we are transformed by
beholding one final quotation this is my
favorite of all Sons and Daughters of
God page
337 by beholding
Christ by talking of
him by
beholding the loveliness of his
character we become
changed changed from glory to
glory and what is
Glory
character and he becomes changed from
character to character thus we see that
there is a work of
purification that goes on by beholding
Jesus so what is the
genuine practice of Christian
meditation it is not emptying your mind
but it is taking time to fill your mind
as Ellen White referred to it many times
filling memories
Hall with the beauty of Christ's
character with the beauty of scripture
and as we do that folks we will be
changed it's a law of life we will be
changed into the likeness of the
Glorious character of Jesus
Christ so let's not
get
deceived by Satan's
counterfeit which is emptying the mind
to hear the voice of God independently
of
scripture let's
focus on the objective reality of
scripture and see Jesus as he is in all
of his Beauty let us pray Father in
heaven we thank you for giving us your
holy
word if we didn't have that we would be
left only to our own imaginations to our
own subjective
experience and everybody has a different
subjective experience so you would have
as many rules of Faith as you have
individuals thank you for giving us an
objective external source of truth that
we can count on for sure which applies
to everyone everywhere at all
times I ask Lord that as a result of
being here last evening and today
that we will make it a point to practice
genuine Christian meditation help us
Lord to spend time in prayer to spend
time in studying your holy scriptures
and in talking to others about how
wonderful Jesus is in this way Lord we
know that we will be
transformed into the image of Jesus this
is the desire of our hearts in his name
we pray amen
[Music]